[Music]
guys I am back from the Star Wars
Celebration in Anaheim California I had
an amazing time I met a lot of my great
friends from YouTube and I met a lot of
you guys I'm currently working on a
video compiling all the best costumes
and panels and people that I met
including a whole bunch of footage of
awesome time spent with you guys that's
going to be up very soon and that is why
I didn't have my review of the Batman V
Superman dawn of Justice trailer up when
I would have liked to was across the
country so I had to fly there I was
going to panels every day there was no
way I could have filmed it I had one
small couple hour window just to do the
force awakens trailer video and I saw
the schmoes and I was like go over here
get in this video and it worked out but
besides that I couldn't do anything else
except have an amazing time that video
compiling my whole trip is going to be
up very soon but let's talk about Batman
V Superman another film that I am very
much anticipating along with Star Wars
now when it comes to Man of Steel I
thought the film was fine it was nice to
see Superman actually doing something
besides lifting really heavy things
there were a lot of problems with the
script and the tone was all over the
place but from what I'm hearing and from
the looks of this trailer this is going
to be a much better movie in this
trailer we open up and we hear a whole
bunch of people who are talking about
Superman and they're talking about
public perception of Superman we're
seeing this statue of Superman and this
statue is portraying Superman as a
messianic idol I mean let's face it he's
basically Jesus in these movies and
there are many shots in this trailer of
people kneeling before him and people
reaching up to the sky after him as if
they want to touch him and this is where
Batman comes in we get some voiceover
from Jeremy Irons is Alfred talking
about anger and rage we see Affleck
staring at his bat suit and he looks
great know I've said this from the
beginning I've been pumped about Ben
Affleck ever since the beginning if you
don't believe me you can go back and
watch the video I made on the day of
that announcement I was excited about it
and the shots of Batman in this trailer
are so Batman II they're perfect I mean
it looks exactly like the kind of Batman
that I want to see this grizzled older
extremely tough Dark Knight Returns
style Batman there's even a little
Batman Easter egg in this trailer you
see the Riddler's question mark now if
that could have anything to do with the
movie I highly doubt it it's probably
just a nice nod to the fans and that's
cool that Zack Snyder is aware of those
things and he's giving us fun little
things that we can just have in there
to kind of make a smile does it matter I
guess not really doesn't have anything
to do with the story doesn't make it
better
not really so I guess it's just kind of
cool it's cool I like it and the
eventual confrontation between Batman
and Superman is teased will receive
Batman in his incredibly awesome armored
suit NES Superman do you bleed you will
now some people have said that voice is
not Batman's which wouldn't make any
sense to me and would seem like a bait
and switch and in the IMAX trailer
screen today which I did not get a
chance to see apparently there is an
extra shot of Batman Superman flying
towards each other to clash or something
I don't know that's cool my question is
if that is Batman's voice which it seems
like it is does the suit that he wears
the mechanical armored suit change his
vocal patterns in some way because it's
a very mechanical robotic sounding voice
it's obviously processed and changed so
I'm assuming that they're going to have
something to explain that maybe even in
his normal Batman cowl he has something
that changes his voice which would
increase his disguise which would make
sense because they honestly want us to
think that he's able to make that
mechanical sound with his voice I just
don't believe that hopefully it's
something that the suit is actually
changing in some way all in all guys I
am excited for this movie I like the way
the trailer looks it does look better
than Man of Steel the Scimitar fee looks
great I'm excited to see Batman with Ben
Affleck and I'm excited to see Henry
Cavill back as Superman and of course
the appending battle is going to be
great I just really hope that it's not a
CGI fest of cartoon or I just hope that
it looks as realistic as it can be
because I really don't want to see a
cartoon Superman and a cartoon
Batman punching each other unless I'm
watching a DC animated film guys what
are your thoughts on this trailer I'm
excited for it I can't wait for it is
there anything I missed in the trailer
that maybe I should have brought out let
me know below and thank you so much as
always for watching I look forward to my
Star Wars Celebration compilation video
featuring tons of you guys who came up
to me and were so awesome it was really
humbling meeting you guys and I honestly
loved it I can't wait to share it with
you as always if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]